liebe leute ich höre tatsächlich auf die
pixum der online talkshow auf youtube es
gibt also in zukunft keine promi talks
mehr los da nicht irgendwie ein bushido
dort kein fragen lotto schluss aus ende
vorbei
nahezu alle promis die nicht bei drei
auf dem baum waren haben sich von mir
befragen und deshalb gibt es jetzt etwas
ganz anderes science and fiction
wissenschaft und fiktion das was mich
wirklich interessiert ich werde die
coolsten phänomene erklären mache die
verrücktesten experimente und auch ganz
normale und erkläre dinge mal etwas
anders
pixum ist also der kanal auf dem er in
zukunft mehr über die spannendsten dinge
der welt erfahren nur eins bleibt das
karo ich freue mich also auf euch als
zuschauer mit fragen anregungen und
ideen für verblüffende video stellt also
hier unter dem video eure fragen und ich
versuche sie so bald wie möglich zu
beantworten oder seid live dabei am 14
12 2010 18 uhr live hangout im rahmen
des google plus adventskalenders da
könnte auch schon fragen stellen ich
versuche sie zu beantworten oder 0 47
mir für später also bis dann bleibt dran